جديد الى مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس من هناك
مراسل الجزيره مؤمن اشرافي هل ترا اي جديد
على المشهد وتطوراته المدنيه والانسانيه
مؤمن نعم ازدار على الصعيد الانساني ارتفع
عدد الشهداء قبل قليل الى 52 الى 52 شهيدا
وصلوا الى مجمع ناصر الطبي حتى هذه اللحظه
بالاضافه الى اكثر من 100 مصاب من تمكنوا
من الوصول سواء عر سيارات الاسعاف او
بسيارات مدنيه او مشيا على الاقدام الى
مجمع ناصر الطبي وردتنا قصه قبل قليل وحسب
ثلاث اطفال وصلوا الى مجمع ناصر الطبي هم
من عائله غنام هم عائله نازحه كانوا
يقطنون داخل كرافان بسيط عباره عن غرفه
بسيطه متنقله عندما وصلت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه الى محيط منطقه ابراج طيبه
دهست هذه الدبابات هذا الكفان الصغير وهم
نائمون في ساعات الليل المتاخر ما ادى الى
ارتقاء رب هذه الاسره الوالد وابنته
الكبرى بينما لم يبقى سوى ثلاث اطفال
وصلوا الى مجمع ناصر الطب الطبي قبل قليل
جراحهم متفاوته ووضعهم النفسي ووضع صعب في
ظل غياب الام عن مدينه غزه
وا تقول الفتاه التي تبلغ من العمر 11
عاما ان دبابه واليه عسكريه اسرائيليه
دهست الكفان وهم نائمون ما ادى الى
استشهاد والدها واختها الكبرى وهم نجوا
باعجوبه من عمليه الدهس من القبل الاليه
العسكريه وبشكل مباشر على هذا الكفان هم
ينتظرون كحال المئات الذين وصلوا من
المصابين الى داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي
ينتظرون في طوابير طويله لتلقي العلاج
اعداد محدوده من الكوادر الطبيه امكانيات
معدومه تقريبا لتقديم العلاج للجرحى
طوابير طويله تنتظر دورها في غرف العمليات
اصبحت ممتلئه عن بكره
ابيها الاطباء يلجؤون الى مبدا المفاضله
بين الجرحى من هو يستطيعون انقاذ حياته
يدخلون الى الى غرف العمليات الحالات
الميؤوس منها لا يتعاملون معها بسبب
الاعداد الكبيره من الاصابات ونقص الكوادر
الطبيه ونقص المعدات والامكانيات اللازمه
لتشغيل غرف
العمليات ال المخزون المخزون الطبي من
المستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
و كافه المستلزمات هي مخزون يقارب يشارف
على الانتهاء داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي شكرا
جزيلا لك من مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن شرافي شكرا جزيلا لك